لا غنى لكم بعد اليوم فلتموتوا اتفاقيه
الحبوب تم الغاءها والدول الغربيه تصرخ
اين ارضغن لينقذنا من بطش الدب الروسي
واوكرانيا تضرب جسر من جديد والرد الروسي
لا يتاخر وبعد ترددها لفتره طويله واشنطن
تتخذ خطوه جريئه ضد موسكو بينما تعلن كييف
استعاده مناطق كبيره في ضخمه بل هي كذلك
والاستخبارات الامريكيه والالمانيه تنكشف
عورتهما امام العالم
[موسيقى]
وبريطانيا اول دوله اوروبيه تضع قدمها بين
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ والمغرب يصدم
العرب ويفتح احضانه للقوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
موسكو تقسو على الغرب
بعد انقطع بوتين شريان الطاقه على
الغربيين حان الوقت ليقطع شريانا اخر وليس
على الغرب وحدهم هذه المره بل وعلى كل
حلفائهم انه شريان الغذاء وهنا كانت وزاره
خارجيه الروسيه قد اعلنت ان موسكو سحب
الضماناتها الامنيه لشحنات الحبوب واغلقت
الممر الانسانيه في البحر الاسود وكان
الروس يقولون وبلوني بقى لو لقيت
فمتى ستكون المقابله للمقابله شروط وكان
الرئيس الروسي بوتين قد سردها قبل ايام
مطالبا بالتعهد بازاله العقبات امام مسار
صادرات الاغذيه والاسمده الروسيه والتي لم
تتحقق في المعاهدات السابقه ليضيف بوتين
انه لم يتم الوفاء بالهدف الرئيسي للاتفاق
وهو ضمانه وصول امدادات الحبوب الى الدول
الافقر هناك اكدت الرئاسه الروسيه امكانيه
عوده روسيا الحبوب على الفور بمجرد تنفيذ
الجزء الروسي منها وكما يقولها المثل
اليمني حقكم حق وحق الناس مرق اي ما هو
لكم تاخذونه وما هو لنا لا ناخذه هل يرضخ
الغرب لمطالب بوتين هذه المره من جهتها
نددت وناحت الكثير من دول الغرب بالانسحاب
الروسي من اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب اذ اعتبرت
الولايات المتحده القرار عملا وحشيا
سيتسبب في معاناه الكثيرين بدوره اكد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الاجراء الروسي غير
مبرر ويعد استخداما للغذاء كسلاح في
الصراع اما الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وهو وسيط اتفاقيه الحبوب كالعاده فقال انه
مقتنع بان الرئيس بوتين يريد تمديد صفقه
الحبوب لكن دون تحديد موعد بالتوقيع على
تجديد تلك الصفقه والعالم في حيره من امره
فلتبدا
بالانتشار في العالم لان روسيا واوكرانيا
تؤمنان ثلث صادرات الحبوب للعالم ومن صفقه
الحبوب الى لهيب المعارك الاوكرانيه هنا
اشعلت مجددا في جسر القرن وللمره الثانيه
خلال اشهر الجسر الذي يعتبر الاطول في
اوروبا لتعلن لجنه مكافحه الارهاب الروسيه
بانما وقع بالجسر القرم هو هجوم ارهابي
نفدته مسيرتان البحريتان اوكرانيتان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لم يصمت هذه
المره وتوعد بالرد على تلك الهجمات مشيرا
الى ان وزاره الدفاع جينز المقترحات
المناسبه للرد وهناك توعد نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي الروسي لمتر مدريديف بتفجير
منازل القاده الاوكرانيين وذلك ردا على
عمليه التفجير ليشتعل غضب الدب الروسي
مجددا لتعد البرازيل مره اخرى وتعرض
الوساطه على موسكو حيث قال وزير خارجيه
البرازيل المرافييرا بين موقف بلاده حول
ضروره مناقشه سبل التسويه السلميه في
اوكرانيا يثير الاهتمام في العالم وعربت
عده دول عن الاستعداد للانضمام الى هذه
الجهود فهل يقبل الطرفان بالوساطه ميدانيا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها صدت
15 هجوما للجيش الاوكراني على محوري
695 جنديا للعدو خلال اليوم الماضي وهذه
هي الارقام التي اعلن عنها الموقع الروسي
للحكومه الروسيه ونحن نتصفح المصدر
كالعاده اما في بخ مود فعلنه القوات
الاوكرانيه استعاده منطقه تقدر مساحتها
بثمانيه عشر مربعا من الاراضي في شرق
وجنوب البلاد وكعادتنا نعرض لكم المصدر
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه استعاده منطقه
تقدر مساحتها بثمانيه عشر كيلومترا مربعا
من الاراضي في شرق وجنوب البلاد ومنها
مناطق تقع في اتجاه مدينه
لتؤكد نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه مليار
ان التقدم رفع اجماليه مساحه الاراضي التي
استعادتها حتى الان منذ بدء الهجوم المضاد
الى اكثر من 210 كيلومترات مربع وبخصوص
الهجوم المضاد ولكن بعيدا عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وبعد تردد لفتره طويله استجمعت
واشنطن شجاعتها ليعلن مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي ان البيت الابيض وافق على تدريب
الاوروبيين للطيارين الاوكرانيين على
مقاتلات اف 16 هنا وافق الامريكانو فقط
على التدريب فمتى سيرسلون الطائرات انها
لحياه طويله وهنا ننتقل الى التسريبات
والتي لا امريكا وحلفائها حيث افادت صحيفه
الالمانيه بان وكالتي المخابرات الامريكيه
والالمانيه تعرضت لتسرب بيانات خمسه
الاف6500 اسم من موظفيها بسبب استخدام
برنامج مكافحه فيروسات عبر الانترنت
[موسيقى]
قويه فكيف ستكون رده فعل واشنطن بعد
انكشاف الالاف من جواسيس واستخباراتهم لقد
كشفت عورتكم يا هؤلاء فيا لها من فضيحه
مدويه وليس ببعيد الان ان الاستخبارات
الروسيه والصينيه يعملون على فرز تلك
الكشوف حاليا لان اغلب شركات صناعه
المكافحات هي في الاصل روسيه وعلى راسها
شركه كيسبرسكي وبين هذا وذاك فادت صحيفه
بولس لان سكان اوروبا باتوا اكثر فقرا وسط
ارتفاع تضخم وانخفاض القوه الشرائيه بينما
يرتفع مد مواطنين الامريكيين
الاحداث والتطورات اعلنت صحيفه
انطلقت من ميناء تشنج داونلي اجراء
مناورات الشمال التفاعل 2023 المشتركه مع
روسيا التي ستقام في بحر اليابان وذلك
للحفاظ على امن القنوات البحريه
الاستراتيجيه بشكل مشترك والاستجابه
للتحديات الامنيه المختلفه هدد اكثر من
100 من كبار الطيارين المقاتلين ونخبه
الكوماندوز ومتخصصين بالاستخبارات
الالكترونيه في قوات الاحتياط بالجيش
الاسرائيلي بعدم الاستمرار في خدمتهم
التطوعيه والسبب رفضهم للتعديلات القضائيه
عين رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه للجيش
الاسرائيلي هرسها ليبيا شارون ايتاح كاول
ملحق عسكري في المغرب في خطوه ترفع مستوى
تطور العلاقات الامنيه اسرائيل والمغرب
افادت قناه سكاي نيوز بان بريطانيا وقعت
على اتفاقيه انضمام الى الكتله التجاريه
لدول المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وسيزيد ذلك
تجارتها مع بلدان الكتله عبر خفض رسوم
الجمارك على الواردات وبذلك باتت بريطانيا
اول دوله اوروبيه تنضم الى هذه الكتله
التجاريه الاقليميه التي تضم استراليا
وبروناي وكندا وتشيلي واليابان وماليزيا
والمكسيك ونيوزيلندا
وسنغافوره وفيتنام
[موسيقى]